uh if someone is actually never
sorry if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
i think probably watch
uh four weddings in a funeral
um that would be the first thing i say
and then
you kind of unravel from there and you
can go in one direction or you can go on
the other but um it's a pretty sort of
yeah it's a good one
you've done a lot of things it's short
so if you don't like it you don't have
to watch any others it doesn't take up
too much time
i don't think anyone would start
watching that and be like oh this is a
bad movie you know that's that's not
going to happen um you've done a lot of
theater work and i love talking to
actors you've done theater work is there
a particular place that you love to
perform and what is the favorite place
that you love to watch something at oh
gosh um
that's really hard question because
there i just love
performing
um but i think it depends what um
but i was lucky enough to be on broadway
at um the i forgot the name of the
theater how awful um
i've got the name anyway i was lucky
enough to be on broadway um in a chekhov
play called the seagull and it was the
first time a chekhov play had been put
on on broadway and it was
just the most fantastic experience it
was bringing
chekhov and particularly that play the
seagull to
that audience was just one of the great
thrills of my life
but it's a huge theater it's like 1200
seats or something and then
another really great experience in the
theater has been playing to really small
audiences of sort of 300 people you know
it just changes every time it's really
great
um jumping into why i get to talk to you
i want to start with congrats on the
show uh my favorite part is when episode
six ended and there was a tease for the
next six because i wasn't i didn't know
that was happening and i was very happy
um what was it about this these scripts
and this material that said oh i want to
do this
i think it's the mixture of tension and
humor and um the riveting plot and the
plot within a plot within a plot you
know the people's
um how people let their sort of
narcissism and
and their ideas and their own personal
ambitions get in the way of their sense
um and how
how
well
observed these characters are how
mccarran has created these characters
and then
and then will smith has done something
else with them and and it's
it's it's really you know and it brought
in new ones and changed others and
you know sort of made a whole different
thing that holds up really really well
um and i think that
you know that that whole that whole
jar is not something that i'm
particularly drawn to as an actor i mean
i like watching it
quite but it's not something that i'm
i'm going to sort of oh there's a new
spy thing i must watch it um but i think
the the study of
people in it is really really great i'm
really interested in people you know i
like seeing how people behave in certain
way in certain situations and i think
that um the characters are all so well
developed um
[Music]
yeah i think that's what pleased me and
the humor in it because there's such
such a lot of humor
and i've never read anybody like jackson
lamb on on paper and i've never hoped
we'd never discover anyone else like
jackson lamb on film
i i think that's also uh um and gary is
just so good at jackson you know um uh
but one of the things i like about it or
one of the many things is that you
typically see
spies like a spy show is about the best
of the best and this is not about the
best of the best it's you know it's
about real people um with humor as you
said yeah about real people have been
doing their best but their best isn't
good enough
um and that is a very relatable thing
you know people are people make mistakes
and
and sometimes it's the end of the world
and sometimes it isn't and um
the whole film the thing even i'm not
going to say what what it starts with
but um you know it is
it's very very
um
it's easy to identify with these
characters i think
apart from perhaps diana taverner but
that was my job
right with actually with your character
do you think is there a line that she
will not cross or is everything fair
game in the pursuit of justice if you
will um for herself justice for herself
um yeah
yeah
it is
everything is fair game
she will not she will stop at nothing
she has no redeeming qualities
that we have discovered yet
i i'm wondering how that's going to be
happening in the next six or if there's
anything you know who knows
if one of the things i love about uh is
talking with people about the way things
are made um like learning things that
you wouldn't normally hear about so for
soon to be fans of this series is there
anything that you think they might be
like surprised to learn about the making
of the show
well we made it in um
lockdown
um with very strict
rules about what we were allowed to do
what we weren't allowed to do
um so that was a that was a bit of a
challenge you know because it's very as
you know and we all i think everyone on
the most you know most people knew
how difficult it is to communicate when
half of your faces is um
um hidden
um and
you know that was that required extra
concentration what i found to be
particularly challenging because i've
never done it before
was long-form
tv
and
um i had a conversation with my
co-actor um sophie ochnado about this
because she does has done a lot of it
and she says no it's really difficult
you really have to pace yourself and you
have to get used to
keeping things
you can't you have to remain
concentrated for a much much much longer
period because you can't go away for the
six weeks that you've got off between
one scene and the next time you're
needed you can't go away and forget
about it all you have to keep it all
there
and that is i find that really really
difficult um
not it's not about forgetting but it's
about being in the atmosphere and being
in the thick of it because you want to
be in the thick of it you want to be in
the
in the in the world of um of regents
park or in the world of um sloughhouse
you want to be in the world of
the canal at nighttime um you want to be
able to dive in there straight away and
it's really hard to do when there's a
huge great separation of weeks months
sometimes between each time you shoot it
do a day's work
and it was it was very challenging very
very challenging that to me
you know you're all like stop stop stop
stop
that's so interesting i wouldn't even
have thought about that but um um uh or
i already have to go i'm just gonna say
again i am a really big fan thank you so
much for giving me your time and i wish
you nothing but the best thank you very
much you too